today I want to tell you about a couple
of milestones sharing your resource and
made a small request
at first the milestones if you're
subscribed to this channel then you'll
know that I upload a lot of videos and I
mean a lot of videos how many recently I
put up my 1000th video and that's a
little over three every day for every
school day since I started I think that
makes this a perfect opportunity to say
thank you to some really important
people you see even though I shoot and
edit and upload it all by myself I don't
make these videos alone I get tons of
help from lots of people you almost
never see them but you almost certainly
heard them because I'm talking about the
students in my classes I want to thank
you guys for being patient with me as I
setup for each lesson thank you for
helping me get out my equipment put it
away whenever I've needed a hand and
most importantly thank you for putting
up with having all this gear in the
middle of your lessons so that we can
share our classroom with the whole world
I'm convinced that one of the big
reasons people find these videos so
helpful is because I'm not usually
talking to myself I'm explaining to you
actual people in the classroom who are
asking questions to correct things
giving me confused looks so I know when
I need to clarify an explanation and
make an eye contact to encourage me and
keep me going so to everyone who's ever
been in my classes when I filmed thank
you you're awesome and these videos
wouldn't be what they are without you
the other master I want to share with
you was one that I hardly noticed even
though I actually passed it a while ago
I get access to all kinds of statistics
about who's using the channel and how
much and sometime in the last month I
passed 1 million minutes of watch time
actually at the time I'm shooting this
video it's actually a fair bit over a
million when I saw that I thought wow
that seems like a big number but I
couldn't really picture what it actually
meant I thought well how many hours is
that equal to so I divided by 60 and
found it's something like 18,000 hours
well ok but I still don't know what that
looks like so here's what I did to try
and understand that figure a little
better and my school all the lessons are
slightly different lanes but the average
length of a lesson is about 51 minutes a
classroom teacher teaches 22 and a half
of
every week that's 1150 two minutes or
about 19 hours face-to-face time with
students each week and there are usually
40 weeks of school each year so that
means that a teacher would on average
teach 768 hours of lessons each year
okay and that's a lot of numbers but
here's the point if you put it all
together that means the amount of time
people have watched the channel
represents more than 23 years of
classroom teaching 23 years that's my
boy so I guess I just wanted to say wow
and thank you very part of this crazy
experiment with me right those are the
milestones I want to quickly tell you
about a new resource I've made a whole
bunch of different websites over the
last 15 years and recently I made a new
one to gather the teaching and learning
materials that I've made all together so
if you go to mr. woo tubecon which I've
had before but redesigned recently
you'll see my YouTube playlist all
categorized by course and if you explore
a little you'll find my blog as well as
a whole bunch of worksheets and
resources for students and teachers so I
hope that's helpful to you and it makes
it easier to find stuff that'll be
useful finally a request over the last
couple of months I've met quite a few of
you people who've watched videos on the
channel when I've been out and about at
a careers Expo I attended and even just
when I've been out shopping I found that
surprising but really cool to meet
people and find out how the channels
been helpful to you it made me realize
that I would love to hear that from more
to you so I want to ask something of you
if you've watched any of my videos if
you've found the channel helpful at all
I'd love for you to record a short video
saying hi tell me who you are and where
you're from
whether you're a student or a teacher an
individual or a whole class of you from
Australia or some other part of the
world I'd love to see in Hue so I know
who I'm connecting with on the other
side of the Internet then upload it
somewhere and send me a link through
email or Twitter or Facebook and I
really look forward to hearing from you
thanks guys